ecco noto già da tempo su la letteratura
scientifica si di mera bene questa
scossa sa classe educazione e bilingue e
sull'opportunità di poi spithill ricerca
savatta salis università dite di un
borgo e non fettine limburgo dimostranti
che ispettivo sughi crescenti con su
bilinguismo tenenti mathas a bruce
opportunità risi trn scintille brucia in
altra materia spero come la matematica
non hai la sardegna che est un'isola
pizzica 25 mila m squadra su un milione
e mezzo di abitanti si può dire essere
uno terreno i reali pò fà foresti di
gusto sistema di apprendimento però e
succede a 11 fenomeno culturali ninis
ultimo usano su sa limba estrae stretti
ha abbandonata esistete abbandonare ago
motivo su differenti un motivo di
imposizioni linguistica poi tra woody
proibiva chi sono e su sardo in esisti
tuzione siniscola se nei seminari su
però vinas e con un meccanismo di
censura spontanea questa isba bus e
smamma saben santa che presenti stesso
senso rowe con italiano di ante pianta
poteri thanei 1 sull'opportunità di
bruce manna renascer in sasso cerati lei
ci appaga pago custa abitudini se perdi
a essa sardegna è stata divisa in due
parti su una varti in c punti b da sony
ancora su sardo che sinistra normalmente
con ispettivo sottoscala scint in sardo
ea tra la zona in castello sarà pitt
alina trash partisi anni a serie investi
praticamente sparisce da uno spareggio
al najdi si si intende di una persona
ma se il momento l'obiettivo di chi
suona in sardo pari di spanto ecco
quindi costo panay chi poi a pesargli un
obiettivo in sardo in castello s
un'esperienza in un ambiente che devo a
definire ostili un ambiente non non
favorevoli questa cosa a parte li
vendono commenta da sé esperienza che
non avevo stato difesa invece saranno
tutti io in limba sarda ma non fate in
limba sarda volta una contingenza una
situazione particolare che capitavano su
in 3d ma salita san mames ti spagnolo è
tanto il sucidio giusta questa
particolarità di naraus tanto tocca la
descrive questa esperienza concretamente
in effetti con gli studi a serino santi
e sante imparare
toccherà a comprendere un avaria cosa
seidimoda interessi importanti
massimamente i pochi ne pensa a
destituire un'esperienza commenta
commenta gusta la prima la motivazione
costumi pari di mete importanti chi sa
motivazioni da presa e uno di pillon
avvertivano villa in sardo in un'atra
limba non c'è sti un caso un'importanza
as ideologia questa mera vincent taranto
1 estinta intendenti lista quando
imparerà sa limba voglia di passare su
degli usi con sa limba no o no stessa
cosa effetti naturale naturale volta si
debba field della bubble che su un
assalto anti trasmissivo annus e secolo
su una lim
non si comprende dicano sud e peso se
gari cus trasmissioni e noi imparare a
ispettivo disabilitati sito sostenersi
tutti sbabo si ci pensa al beni imparata
e stilosi sabilità richiedenti a fare un
gioco a risolvere un problema sa limba
responabilità questo strumento
quando devo creare una sospensiva che
tenga su doveri da trasmettere voluto
stabilità dico casa li investe una grave
comprende riscossa colloquia rimarrà
scholes
quindi siamo attivazioni e katie gusta
desideri una
una tradizione in cu stu fa parte mia
nessun elemento nuovo che voglia di
andare contro ad essa esperienza che
devo al passato taddeo secondo te cosa
che venendo nobody una mamma che esiste
un'altra sardo effettiva dovrà dei suoni
sparente su con esami così con no
sospinge suggestionante ristoranti
italiani fatto una cosa nuova come poco
curiosa questa una cosa di te non ho che
non ti perdono però messo una cosa che
attivato per calmanti con ivano
conoscenza crossman a chi devo contento
di avere utenti indoona limba limitare
faccia essere accusati denis anti su
però sud operi michele trasmettere cussu
caparre cio non deve operazioni sinistra
naso meccanica sarà non è tanto gusto
estesa motivazioni mi vari dimena
importanti commenta doveri sociali
affacci destituiti degenerazioni snoda i
denti su diritti da conoscere e da po di
pratica iss a trasmissioni culturali con
una cosa colori pivot un gioco decente
punti in casa troppo o in sardegna che
non conoscenti salim non può denti e
partecipare a sagre missioni gusto
culturali tutti svoltasi a kiss anziano
si libro sulla televisione un'intervista
impara da sé rinvasata questo succede
dott estivi passando indenne anche dando
fu stessa motivazioni un elemento
volesse della tecnica certo la prima
cosa deve stare con i testi ca nun suo
nesti che io imparavo su sardo a sils
esigenti cannes dono si intende di
narrati dai s'impara os usato no non so
e sso keystone ap social testa una cosa
meta diversa questo problema le star
invest una sovrastruttura chydenius non
si faccia 6 spears e sfizioso non
docenti
keystone anche una lingua diversa veneto
luc o dici dandosi su babbo dinara
ammessa e mamma dinara tablet a san mama
di una realtà tablet su babbo di 40 anni
ma non senti cui di un francese su
questo nuovo e del sarto e cantù sta
cosa che non provavo a fare custodio
credo che sti di avere sulle elemento
tecnico importanti e sta non confondere
dandosi uno di storia d'una limba dei
pixo nervetti questa lingua maya mistura
ecu stessa cosa a ginosa stato
dell'unione di sette hanno sì noi è un
dopo norma in a1 fuori tutto italiano e
il successo abitua nomina il mayon vuoi
dell'italiano quando non conosci di un
nuovo ed oggi ancora minara di turo
suonare in italiano se non conoscete
solo sul web ma sono abitudini normali
non c'è nulla commenti pone sempre a
varrenti in sarei nick ha chiesto una
cosa abbastanza importanti da un'onda
come correggio dina simon poeta non
depressi programma gli una cosa che gli
stanchi di tempi da essere una cosa una
cosa naturale poi riscossa spendi titolo
segnanti certo come questa arrivava 5 se
sanno tanto a fuco mensa va di nargis
aggettivo si poneva fatto e non prima
potrà certo non soltanto da link una
complicazione inclusivo e tampona i lidi
spagnolo soggettivo secondi prima e
sardo secoli dopo quindi ha proprio una
bella una bella opposizioni del sistema
è un'altra cosa che uso città di bari
sempre a varenne il suo campo di stessa
tecnica e si specchia goor sud e non
cristiana in domus italiano ma avete
questo motivo quando confonde potessi
commenti san mama dati sono vecchi e
solo spagnolo le offerte solo su sardo
as intende degli store hai un'altra
limba diversa chi non cristiana vaso con
esso secondo no so che ad essi deposti
possa essere una cosa un opaco di podi a
confondere suo ep quindi ecco il satin
cricchetto tutto gusta una cosa naturale
gestionali e basta e dalla sayan las
cosas arici commenti del pd comandate
pinta andata certo che una volta
cos'è il curioso no una di una mamma di
un orecchio accertava pochi danni a
potrà ritornare a susa da subito di
narrare è mai c
insomma vi pice da paesi non farsi si
interesso su se sono stato un po vita
mia non ho mai vissuto questo no non ci
sono ancora sorridere che stona di
questione era già stata invasa questo
non ci sono ancora però vs sa aspetto
desidero logie a narrare tuta in euro in
su sangue
giusto quindi che su un aspetto sa
tecnica e su una cosa importante non
decisiva meda naturale si tratta da the
day comprendere i testi sa trasmissioni
che non so se in parenti commenta una
scuola un assenso
la trasmissione pratiche su una cosa
diversa onesta imparare una lingua in
ghisa scola bene un'altra cosa
abbastanza importanti e sti esperienza
commenti nostro successo abituato
potrebbero appena un pò non esiste più
tim per high tone un'educazione in sardo
in un ambienti ostili poi pagando un uso
andrea su questa strada e sa gente sia
catarra che sono i più di sensato sensi
di mare para l'ha spuntata questa non fu
una cosa non fu una cosa naturale
potresti normali keane che sa città di
gustosi si pagano però diamo sacrati ha
donato agosto dopo un'avaria egida sta
dopo aver pensato a sé esperienze a me
succede una cosa che ognuno è mera
maniera mela rapporti naraus o meno a
metà gara cadute o intendo 1 bug una
mamma che visto nel testo italiano a 1
bp come mi pare di naturale ma è
naturale in meta mi parli corpo una cosa
legge questa segua bit cloud maniera
differente quindi con hi sun relazione
documenti ha abituato a tutto ciò
massimamente agosto mi vedono va un
effetto strano cannobio che fonti ba bus
e mamma sai cristiane tra sardo fra dei
suoi chi sono e da conso bello è
cambiata limbadi che stona con a karima
commenti di peso tanto non possa
comprendere gusto o non si tu voglia
imparare quindi lotus abituato
è questa questa situazione e dona lavoro
poiché il suo primo momento un po di
parri loro difficili di a rinascere a
fare questa esperienza
ma democristiano con me i punti bastata
su una carica di gila sa ho pagati
assolutamente naturali in itis tonale in
sardo con il saldo che illumina testi sa
limba materna nessuna luna questa
un'altra una tra l'inps che è poi questo
fatto che dell'esperienza che impara da
cosa sanno su scuro poi casa cacao che
commenti funzionerà su meccanismo di
apprendimento des imparo del pp una
gamba record ancora è all in con un
fenomeno interessante supremo quando
sesta cacao che l'impresa o testi una
vocale finali che si impara meta quando
si investa catalano jade 12 ducale anche
una volta commerciava pone risale a
savini del web su castigliano sud è
furioso italiano di sanna normali sì
però non mi sa cataldo come di
funzionare l'apprendimento dei commenti
kant 1 adattata una grande
interpretazione de sa limba commentata
ad imperare tali una volta kaling una
cosa comica foro secondo loro in uso
impera camera metà beni è stata cosa
curiosa castiga suri più kim apprendi di
salim barici il suo primo momento non
dona l'attenzione salima massa persona
non auguro ai semplici comprendi del
rosso sui più con sua mamma con il nonno
su alcuni si sia sacri ustionata
spagnolo ma quando sarà stata in spagna
e in strada una persona di stornara in
spagnolo chi sto rispondendo in italiano
così galan che un amico mio di keystone
era in sardo sto rispondendo in italiano
poi tassa associazioni da vai a ragusa
persona e non con sa limba su cristian
handed e nessun momento del primo usando
di certo noi tra bagnara sak art dono di
sé sa rispondere su viole sugli olii
bosetti quindi custos puntive nome non
meno interessanti che nera al sud e
commenti se ne nasce di dei commenti
funziona la saliva e più scuro sa ancora
a pensai cagando vpt commedia
vai a casa traduzione fra media san mama
commenti si pensi ti chiedevo e samba ma
non comprendiamo si commenti da questa
unione ribas a mamma di cristian ha
donato i sopra dalla traduzione e sa
proprio cosa da pagherà con un amico si
chiama pavan augusto contra
perfettamente associazioni vd
direttamente con woody direttamente con
una scusa persona ecco da uno certo
queste esperienze noi è standard e nanti
si è passata una cosa importante è
l'attenzione della gente e questo gusto
lavarti devo contengono idea abbastanza
positiva terra rammenti perché era
rammenti call in cui una casta o giusta
esperienza di una maniera negativa in
usa genti cannes dubiti questa
esperienza di varese una cosa positiva
da wright appello la cosa curiosa che a
via dunant a cali con organismi da sam b
danni a anni ancora dopo diventa vari
big su bp la tabella uno dei più questo
rende in sardo qualcuna tra le sponde
porosità si impara avuto invece che nera
bello si tuffa esatto su però comprendo
pero su un meccanismo due tank
assistette a una stretta una storia però
gusto e positivo per tagliamo creo qui a
fare questa esperienza e pone in
circolazione un un meccanismo della
trasmissione un'altra cosa curiosa è che
pur in un ambiente ostile o insisto con
queste espressioni poi effettivamente
canosa gente si firmerà mostrare agata
la curiosa questa cosa certo di bolina
che i nostri normali che succederà e
sono documenti nubi tu scriva di
circolarità trasmissioni poi mai si
creerà una relazioni e oi figli un mio
cane andai scola con anzi 21 scanto mai
su sosa direttrici dall'incontro dati
commentati sono effetti di star dugoni
se naturalmente per 36 st cacau di
giudizio nata di preghiera il suo puro
da tornava a bloccargli appiglio mancai
un disagio quale anche una cosa che gli
affari e quindi a pagare una maniera de
presentati allarga e queste esperienze
che positiva
certo
cominciavo a rendere incerta una
letteratura china rara e svantaggi su
titani di un'educazione bilingue chi
bolina i carichi si sa limba non certo
su sardo deve essere italiano e su
spagnolo si inglese o francese su
gaelico non su deus fatta pensando a una
situazione culturali certo da un'onda
provata astrattamente pensando a questo
vantaggio non mi importava mi importava
e tiwari su doveri mills doveri e cus
commenti nantes ecologista sul mondo
della gatta o di una maniera la natura
non da depositi distruggi lì da tempo
escono dal locale e da consegna yes t
gli usa i segmenti della gatta da essa
natura c'è pure la cultura non si può
trasmettere come interesse erba e 6
scosterà sassu mariées montisi poor's ha
cultura ha detto voi su santa decine di
tende all enti vari
ma su doveri nostro e di realizzare
giusta giusta trasmissione quindi scuse
su un'esperienza tranquilla non normali
chi non voleva in nuda ma bolina in meta
e bolinauna riflessioni che no su tenero
poi testo nuova trimonio importanti ide
peso salvari e difendere poi tahara
server a servire non usano mai sacro
solo a suo tempo genitori ad attenere ha
bisogno guru dei questo strumento si
degusta conoscenza